doktor jochen rupp er ist produktmanager
bei bosch und einer der mitentwickler
des kroner schnelltests über den in den
letzten stunden berichtet worden ist und
wir wollen gleich bei ihnen anfangen
dr angeblich ist dieser schnelltest der
anfang april auf den markt kommen soll
inerhalb zweieinhalb stunden bereit ein
ergebnis zu liefern erzählen sie uns
davon wie das funktioniert und was das
verändern wird
richtig guten tag bosch hat einen
schnelltest für den nachweis des corona
tests entwickelt der test ist läuft auf
unsere politik system das ist dieses
gerät sie im hintergrund sehen
und der läuft sehr einfach ab die den
patient wird ein abstrich mit einem
tupfer abgenommen aus dem nasen rachen
bereich und direkt auf eine kartusche
gegeben und diese wird dann in dem gerät
einfach eingegeben und alles andere
läuft vollautomatisch ab und sie haben
es gesagt innerhalb von zweieinhalb
stunden bekommt dann das labor
beziehungsweise der behandelnde arzt
direkt die das ergebnis ob der patient
corona positiv oder negativ ist und kann
so direkt und schnell handeln und es
entfallen weil es ein point of care
tests ist also sprich ich kann sehr nah
am patienten testen viele dauer also
viele langjährige liefer und
transportketten de erzählen sie noch
einmal kurz für uns laien was haben sie
geschafft was ist ihnen gelungen dass
sie diese tests zeit die es dauert bis
zum ergebnis so dramatisch verkürzen
konnten
da ist das zauberwort automatisierung
wenn sie in die labors gehen die
personen die im labor arbeiten das sind
spezialisten die auch teilweise sehr
viel händisch arbeiten und
dementsprechend auch einige weg diese
zeit brauchen wenn sie jetzt einen
automatisierten test haben auch der der
anwender nichts anderes mehr zu tun als
nur noch die kartusche ich kenne sie
auch mal zeigen
das ist dann so etwas erwartet nichts
anderes tun als die probe hier ein eben
zu verschließen und anschließend die
kartusche in das gerät zu bringen sei
die händische
aber es wird minimal und sie können es
im prinzip auch zu jeder tages und
nachtzeit machen und da das alles voll
automatisiert abläuft und wir haben eine
technologie entwickelt mit dem das ganze
auch noch deutlich schneller geht haben
sie einen riesen zeitersparnis doch das
interessiert viele leute vielleicht
könnten sie den tests diese kartusche
noch einmal kurz für uns in die kamera
halten dass wir die noch einmal etwas
genauer sehen könnten ja genau etwas
höher vielleicht noch dann so sieht das
also aus das instrument das gerät der
test mit dem die testzeit für corona
dramatisch verkürzt werden soll